I think it's very clear that for many
American people that I've spoken to they
don't want a lawless king like president
I tell the president bring it because
ten million people signed a petition to
impeach this president what a precedence
do we set when we don't do anything I
think it's hard not to see the special
counsels comments this morning as
anything but an impeachment referral to
the Congress from radicals to moderate
some other statement has brought
Democrats of all stripes in Congress
together so how does the GOP plan to
respond it is newly unified front to
impeach here now is House Minority Whip
Steve Scalise New Orleans congressman
what is the leadership's response to the
Democrat drumbeat that built up over the
last few weeks but you really felt it
today well Laura this has been their
plan all along they've been pushing for
impeachment since the day they won the
majority many of them couldn't hide it
Nadler was bragging about it you saw
others in their own leadership in the
Democrat side saying this was what they
were gonna make their 2-year majority
about frankly this isn't what the
American people elected them to do so I
think there's gonna be a heavy price for
Democrats who go down this path but
they've been planning this which on look
they spent two years in over 30 million
dollars of taxpayer money lying saying
that there was proof of obstruction that
there was proof of collusion there was
none of it in fact the only collusion
that happened where there were people
officials at the Department of Justice
at the FBI even in the Obama
administration who were spying on the
Trump campaign and ultimately when you
look at some of the things that that
happened they had a partisan agenda
within the FBI to take down this
president before he was elected people
are gonna stand for this if they want to
pursue this road it's gonna be again at
the the parallel their majority do you
do our congressmen think that the Senate
Intel committee as others have said
should subpoena Muller to testify before
them he say he pronounced he's not
talking like I mean I know how he could
say that but he did pronounce that today
definitively but should Republicans in
the Senate not take that as a as as
gospel and subpoena him to testify well
Republicans in the Senate
have been focused on doing their job the
job they were elected to do to keep this
country moving forward to get this
country the economy back on track the
Democrats in the house have made it very
clear they don't care about the economy
they don't care about the crisis at the
border keep this in mind Laura the very
committee that has jurisdiction over the
crisis at the border
that's real today more than four
thousand people a day crossing our
border illegally that's the committee
that's chaired by Jerry Nadler that's
focused on this witch hunt on focus and
down down rat holes to try to impeach
the president even when there's no proof
there was no collusion I all right I
want a five second answer okay do the
Democrats think impeachment is their
only chance of beating Trump now no but
it's the only way that they can appease
their radical left base okay cuz Allan
Lichtman is out there saying that that
might be the only way they can win
because he might be projecting Trump
wins in 2020 this is a Hail Mary
congressman thank you for joining us
tonight